the Joe Rogan experience of course
things are getting better but one of the
reasons why these things are getting
better is because people can see
everything you can talk through all the
details yes if you think you could just
cut off the ugly stuff cut off the Nazi
stuff and cut off this stuff and you're
gonna keep people from getting recruited
so you're gonna kill this and you're
gonna deep platform this you're also
gonna you're gonna enforce [ __ ] to
say like there's a reason why they're
silencing us there's a reason why
instead of having people going hey no
you guys are [ __ ] and this is a
stupid idea and you guys are all
ignorant fools and your perception of
things is so off and we're gonna explain
to you while it's off and we're gonna
all like work this out together and when
they say there's a secret elite who's
running this country and wants to
control your life they mean the Jews but
don't thickens up they know shut it down
this but this is their proof they can
point to Twitter and Facebook and they
could also say hey they're picking off
the same exact people and every platform
it's not a coincidence whereas David
Duke is still on Twitter yes yeah of
course that's where's is it
no but it's telling no it's not
hilarious like ha I know but it's yeah
they got rid of Farrakhan they didn't
get rid of David Duke right right
because David Duke serves a purpose what
purpose because he's a good foil for the
left because when David Duke endorses a
Republican look oh the Republicans are
racist when David Duke endorses Ilhan
Omar or Keith Ellison crickets now he'll
be a good bad guy on payroll like if I
was the Democratic Party I'd say look
Dave you think jig is up okay everybody
knows you're never gonna be President
right never gonna really run for office
any more legitimate but she's not that
good valuable how about this David will
give you $400,000 a year all you have to
do is every now and then I'm gonna call
you up but I'm say Dave you know be
interesting it would be interesting if
David Duke endorsed this [ __ ]
and then David Duke just starts talking
about this person being a fine American
and a white nationalist and all these
different just make up a bunch of quotes
and have David Duke put it up there a
lot of people when don't have a shake
that off a lot of people think he's
controlled like not him specifically
from trollop
control-f is this oh that's my favorite
alright when someone's not bad they must
be controlled opposition that is one of
my favorite I love that actually dork it
is a control opposition is someone who
you don't like who hasn't been banned
yet yeah controlled opposition is a
useful idiot
yeah controlled opposition is it's like
when people get into these I've been
accused of being a CIA plant you
probably are probably one of these base
for Anarchy you know that the term
cognoscenti like oh yeah I was in the
know yeah yeah that's a great term and
that's like it's perfect for this it's
like all useful idiot all controlled
opposition I'm in the know I'm one of
the cognoscenti I'm gonna sneak this by
me I understand but meanwhile sometimes
they're right which is why it's really
[ __ ] up it's like sometimes there is
controlled opposition sometimes there is
sometimes just fake websites good times
just because somebody wants yeah
probably yeah somebody wants to win a
lawsuit you know look at this I'm deer
deer like this Casey you're working on
come and look at this website I found
but that's my babies that's why it's so
important for there to be venues for
those people if someone is crazy or
brilliant well often looks the same